the shadowing of the many stories
which we have in all of our languages is
something that i'm going to do more of
in the new year hi there steve kaufman
here
and today i want to talk about goals for
2022 but not in terms of my language
goals but in terms of my activity goals
and i mentioned that in the video that i
did earlier on my language goals
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on uh you know
podcast service please leave a review so
i told you that i was going to continue
focusing on arabic and persian uh i
might dabble a bit in turkish but if we
do launch punjabi or some other south or
at least indian
language at link i will probably
try to get a bit of a sense of that
language as well as tagalog because we
have a lot of punjabi speakers and
filipinos in vancouver whether they
speak whether they're native speakers of
tagalog or not i don't know but i think
most people in the philippines do speak
tagalog
so i'll get my jollies surprising them
say
so those are language goals now activity
goals
uh one of the things that i want to do
in the new year is i want to read more
i looked back to my sort of chinese
learning uh experience
and uh i did a lot of reading more
reading than i'm doing now in my arabic
and persian because i had less audio so
now i can sort of say okay i'm listening
i listened to something i picked it up i
listened to half an hour while preparing
breakfast and cleaning up or i listened
in the car so i've done my thing
actually when i was learning chinese i
read a lot i read a lot and reading is
powerful so i've said in the new year
i'm going to read more and i can read at
link
in sentence mode and i can hear each
sentence if it's time stamped or i can
use the five-second rewind
to to make sure i've got the audio for
that sentence but to some extent i'm
cheating because i'm listening to it at
the same time
and it reading in
arabic and persian is difficult for me
but i'm going to force myself to do more
reading where i don't listen so that i'm
forcing myself to try to rely on my
ability to read the language so that's
one of my goals do more reading and i
definitely would recommend
people that don't neglect your reading
reading is a powerful way for your brain
to get used to the language
that's number one number two i am gonna
do more shadowing i've started i i
mentioned shadowing in a previous video
i've never been a big fan of shadowing
partly because a lot of my listening is
listening to things you know whether it
be uh politics or economics things where
i'm trying to understand what they're
saying and if i shadow then it confuses
me and i can't really hear what they're
saying
but what i have discovered is that our
many stories are ideal for shadowing
because inevitably shadowing by the way
is when you listen to something and you
try to speak at the same time it's not a
pause where you repeat what you heard
it's actually trying to imitate what you
hear
simultaneously
and i just find that that's if i'm
listening to something that i'm
genuinely interested in i find that very
difficult to do and i quickly stop doing
it but i said to myself i'm going to
give this another chance so i tried it
with different kinds of material and i
find that with the mini stories it's
great because the many stories are
simpler
i know the stories
there's so much repetition that if i
miss a word in
the first point of view of the story
i'll pick it up in the second point of
view or i'll pick it up in the questions
and answers so it lends itself to
shadowing second of all
i find that as i listen to these mini
stories which i've listened to many
times
sometimes i lose focus
and so even if i listen to it another
time in another time i'm not gaining
anything because i'm kind of skipping
over the same parts that i did that i
skipped over the last time now i'm
forcing myself to actually say what i
hear and it forces me to focus in and i
notice things that i didn't notice
before and so and i enjoy it now so now
for example i was just on my
nordic track you know cross-country ski
exercising thing that i have at home
and i was listening to my mini stories
in levantine arabic
and i enjoy doing it it's a challenge
it's a it's a challenge to try to
shadow with what you're listening to
uh there's words there that i noticed
that i don't know so now i'm motivated
to go and read them again in the story
and so i think that the shadowing of the
many stories
which we have in all of our languages is
something that i'm going to do more of
in the new year
so more reading more shadowing
and perhaps a little more flashcarding
of phrases i i i'm not convinced that
flash guarding words is all that useful
but with phrases key phrases to focus in
on those phrases that will help me speak
arabic and persian a little bit better
so there you have it a bit of a of a
sense of um some of my language activity
goals for the new year
and i'll leave you the video that i did
on shadowing
and
also another one of the one i did about
my language goals thank you for
listening bye for